we all got New Year's resolutions and
one of mine is to curse less so happy in
New Year's you knew that was coming
I can't change I can't I'm sorry I can't
do it honestly mean that cursing is like
holding the sneeze mmm
Oh what is going on YouTube it's a new
year you miss me what's up yeah you did
yeah you did yeah you did recently I've
decided on something that I had been
broken up about for a while
for the past three years everybody has
been telling me that I had to like this
person back to think he's dope you two I
don't have to like Drake I said it and I
know about 90% of you women out there
like this
oh no heater is look I feel good about
saying I let this [ __ ] off my chest on
my big old titties let my titties flow I
don't have to like drink and you know
why simply because I don't have to but
let me break this down for you number
one I don't like the way the
[ __ ] looks yeah you know as much
as I have listened to his music I never
really got a good look at him until
recently and this cannot just be me but
that dude look weird let me tell you
something I look weird myself so I know
exactly what weird looks like let me
tell you some real recognize real weird
recognized weird and [ __ ] you look
weird
nobody has ever questioned the fact that
he is the first rapper on earth with
African jew-fro you look I'm gonna put
this out there I firmly do not believe
that any man's hair line should be that
strong shits ridiculous that dude hair
line so strong she look like a curly
Kevlar vest is it even real and on top
of that by looking at him I don't even
know what he is epically you have any
idea how confusing that [ __ ] is ain't
nobody gonna racially abused that fool
nobody know what the fears people tell
me he's half black but if he is he is
the most light-skinned brother on earth
this mother to take light-skinned to an
extreme because um he's mixing [ __ ] like
he's half black what's the other side
powder [ __ ] god damn look me in the eye
right now and tell me this that Drake
don't look like a black dude they did my
face ice what if I slap to do powder
will come off in like this number two I
hate the thing he does with his hands
you know what I'm talking about Drake
hands
what if who are you waving to let me ask
you something you try to turn jazz hands
into a hip-hop thing it's not gonna
happen you have any idea what would
happen to somebody freestyle battle
somebody with jazz hands and don't work
I try [ __ ] would not come to this place
some I smack you in the face
sup is with your hands [ __ ] I'll know
I'm try something you I don't know
you know what I'll give it you as an
artist and a rapper some of your lines
know they hot bad look I'll give credit
where credit's due
I'm not a hater but if somebody tells me
one more time that drink is an amazing
singer I'm gonna get a plastic spoon
melt that [ __ ] and step myself in the
eye and amazing sick are you
that's why people use the word amazing
so much it has no meaning this pen is
amazing what amazing [ __ ] is a pet you
know what here's a little riddle for you
why don't you use that pen and draw
yourself a friend [ __ ] get your life
together anybody who says drinking sing
obviously did not see that bull sing
live on The Ellen Show how dare you
Whitney Houston was an amazing singer
Brian McKnight is an amazing singer
when this bull sings it sounds like his
brain is fighting with the lyrics and
[ __ ] I got my eye on Drake I think it
dope on many aspects your don't writer I
think you can rap in [ __ ] too but I
don't like all your [ __ ] and I
especially don't like everybody tell me
that I have to like all his [ __ ] no I do
not you know what we call that we call
that dick running which means you cannot
differentiate from good or bad when it
comes to somebody that you like drink
I'm gonna tell you something right now
if I ever beast you in person this was
gonna go down I'm gonna take out my damn
phone
and we gonna take an Instagram pic like
ass up like this hashtag best friendship
yesterday
hashtag hope he gives me money cuz I'm
broke hashtag light-skinned horse what's
going on YouTube yes I am back and it
was from a long two-week hiatus but I am
back I have returned and it's back to
regular content every Sunday that's
right for those of you have been asking
I upload every Sunday and if not Sunday
if I'm a little late it'll be on Monday
and you can go ahead and check out for
these updates on my Twitter and all my
other social media facets that you can
see up here and down there so a couple
of announcements if you guys don't
already know the pre-orders have now
ended for the winter floral designs on
go-for-broke
apparel calm so now you guys can order
freely but once again remember that
these supplies are very limited so like
last time a lot of you complained it you
didn't get one of those shirts that we
had before
well what supplies are limited that
means when we're out we're out so make
sure you guys go ahead and copy gear as
soon as poss
and the website link is obviously right
below if you guys can't see it right
there second announcement so this year I
will be expanding my channel in the
sense of not starting a new channel but
this channel will have a lot more
content in terms of vlogs so every
Wednesday you guys will be following me
on a journey to my journey of losing
weight
that's right weight loss and getting fit
and focusing on fitness so I'm not going
to go ahead and talk too much about it
because you will get to know it
this Wednesday uh it will be uploaded so
make sure you guys check out for that
video
this Wednesday and if you guys are going
to ask me is gonna be all serious no I
don't have a serious frickin bone in my
body I'm all jokes but you guys will get
to know and understand me on a personal
level and with my waist struggles in my
and my and my journey back to to losing
weight before my injury that I had on my
ankle so come join me on that and see if
you guys can learn something from it so
until next time people I will talk to
you later
hasta luego mañana something I have no
Spanish - here we go oh